next question today hey David would you
support it if the next Democratic
president embarked on trying to reform
the Supreme Court via court packing so
the idea of court packing is that when
you have a party in power they increase
the number of seats on the Supreme Court
and immediately appoint people to that
so you could have a Supreme Court of
nine where you have five conservatives
and four liberals if you get a
Democratic president they could say
we're gonna increase the number of
justices on the court to eleven which is
something that can be done and then we
will immediately appoint to a
progressive or liberal or somewhat
leftist justices and that will swing the
balance to six to five in favor of the
Liberals would I support it this is one
of those things sort of like a
gerrymandering right I like the idea if
it's going to help my side win but I
have to remember that as soon as the
other side gets an opportunity they're
gonna do the exact same thing if the
right party is in power when there's a
redrawing of district lines all of a
sudden many people say hey go ahead draw
crazy districts and make it so that it
favors the party that you like but
you've got to remember that the time of
the next census might come around and
then the party you oppose gets a chance
to do it and then you would say it's
unfair I do think that we need to have a
system that is fair regardless of who is
in power and it can't be so subject to
just the timing and that's why I like
the idea of court packing as a way to
fight back against what I think are
fundamental and justices that have been
carried out by the right with the
Supreme Court like for example saying to
President Obama you've only got a year
left on your term so you're not gonna
get to appoint Merrick garland we're
just going to wait do I think that long
term it's a it's a good strategy no I
don't think it's a good strategy for our
system but what I am willing to say is
given that it's the system we have and
given that the Republicans have been
absolutely despicable when it comes to
this subject I would encourage the next
Democratic president to pack away yeah I
mean it's creative it's thinking outside
of the box and I would certainly
encourage that type of thinking I think
we just got to own up the fact that
Democrats kind of screwed up
the Supreme Court I just had their
chances maybe Ginza Ruth Bader Ginsburg
and Stephen Breyer should have retired
during Obama's term and maybe they
should have fought harder against the
Republicans blocking Merrick garland I
think it's really looking back it's not
looking forward but what can we do now I
think it's only the Merrick garland
issue because the the truth is that
regard I know that you're saying that
Ruth Bader Ginsburg could retire now and
Trump gets to pick a replacement so yeah
it would have been great to just put in
somebody else who's younger during
during Obama's term but in either case
they'd be dealing with the Anthony
Kennedy thing right now so I think the
x-factor really is the garland thing I
think that that is fundamentally where
Democrats didn't do enough and I know
people hear me say that and they say
David
what else could Democrats have done
depends who you ask but I don't think
anybody who is progressive is satisfied
that they did everything that they could
have done that's not a guarantee they
would have ultimately forced garland in
but I don't know too many progressives
who feel as though enough was done I
know some centrist Democrats who feel
that way but I tend to think that that
that's really the major problem so I say
with peace and love I endorse the next
Democrat packing the Supreme Court
absolutely